[Applause]
pft on yahoo sports peter king mike
florio big stories in the national
football league none bigger right now
than tom brady
back in the conference championship
round nine of the last 10 years he's
played at this level but for the first
time not as a member of the new england
patriots the patriots issue didn't even
make it to the playoffs peter does that
mean that tom brady has won
air quotes won the divorce with bill
belichick
you know that's for history to judge and
it's going to have to be
10 years down the road not 10 weeks you
know
every week during the season there would
be some column or two
saying that well belichick won it you
know and that's because the patriots
just killed somebody that week and brady
threw a couple of picks and tampa bay
lost
i mean
and and you know i think that there's
this underlying
thought mike
that if tom brady never left new england
that the patriots would still be in
their glory days
i mean the patriots finished last year
four and five a justifiable
four and five
could do nothing against tennessee in
the playoff game
and i feel pretty sure
that they would have been closer to the
cam newton patriots
of 2020 than the tom brady patriots of
of of
past years for a very simple reason
the skill players on the patriots
are among the worst in the league you
can't play football by yourself
and bill belichick the general manager
and the personnel director and the draft
czar
has been crappy
you know so
you know that's why uh they got the
divorce in the first place
and if you want to say that brady after
winning two straight road playoff games
uh wins the divorce
well this week i guess he does let's see
what happens over a two or three year
period
and amazing to think he's going for
three straight road playoff games and if
he wins he gets to play the super bowl
at home for the first time ever even
though it's a new home for him capping
the year possibly with that super bowl
in tampa i i look
it's it's not going to be an easy answer
like you said it depends on how many
more years tom brady plays and what the
buccaneers or whichever team he may play
for in the future does
as he continues to go age 44 age 45 and
who knows he he may go past age 45 at
this point i've seen no slippage at all
the patriots need a quarterback first
and foremost but you're right they
wouldn't have been a playoff team with
tom brady this year they don't have the
weapons the team wasn't good enough tom
brady isn't that dramatically better
than cam newton that that it would have
made a difference if he would have
stayed so it was good for both sides and
so far it's been better for tom brady
and you know the other thing mike is i
think it was pretty logical to think
that unless tom brady's right arm fell
off between march and september
that there's a very good chance that
tampa was going to have a better year
than new england the one one thing i
kept saying to people i picked the the
bucks to be a very good team this year
as a matter of fact i picked them to go
to the super bowl
but the point and this is not to say hey
look at how smart i am but
look at look at what the bucks were you
know what bruce arian said to me last
march he goes we're a really good team
right now
we just got to be we got to stop turning
it over
and the point is mike they were seven
and seven
going in to play two home games
against lesser teams houston and atlanta
entering the last two weeks of last
season they should have finished nine
and seven but you know jameis winston
threw six picks in the last two weeks
they lost both games so tom brady was
not coming to an empty cupboard
yeah you're absolutely right and he may
face jameis winston twice per year next
year as the saints quarterback of it
plays out that way and winston the guy
who came out of the divisional round
game with the perfect passer rating just
a little footnote to the win that
catapulted the tampa bay buccaneers to
the nfc championship game the bay of
pigs this weekend tom brady if he gets
to the super bowl i think a lot of
people are going to say he definitely
won the divorce with bill belichick but
as peter says
more chapters to be written and we'll
continue to be covering it all here at
pft on yahoo sports thanks for some of
your time we'll see you again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports